Yeah,
I think that that dig is,
is very much,
um,
it's,
it's a living,
breathing thing that is impossible to
kind of wrap your head around in.
You never know what's going to happen on
the side.
I think that's one of the things that
brings a lot of people back to the side.
Like I think that when you take a look
at a,
when I wake up in the morning,
you know,
it's the same feeling in my gut that I
had,
you know,
three and a half years ago and that's
what the hell's in the front page like I
have no idea,
you know,
and it's that freaky kind of,
uh,
um,
you know,
you never know what you're going to,
you're going to get and it's always a,
tends to be interesting and kind of gems
that you wouldn't find anywhere else.
I think that's,
that's what's unique and what keeps
people coming back,
absolutely.
To,
to bring people together and get them
talking and in,
uh,
outside of the online community is a big
deal and it's something that we would
like to continue to,
to do.
Um,
it's important for the company,
uh,
it's important to get users some face
time with you so they can give you and
share their ideas,
their feedback.
Uh,
it's so much better than just an email
coming in.
I'm not only that,
but I think it's important as we kind of
evolve our side as well.
Um,
you know,
one of the things that we'll be
launching in the future,
um,
is our stories suggest feature and um,
we call it our recommendation engine and
it's a piece of software that analyzes
all of the gigs that are happening in
real time across the site and it
compares you to other users.
So you may be dig number 3000 on the
story,
but who were those other 2,999 people.
And what else are they finding that you
might also find interesting?
So when we start to do these things,
we can surface stories very early on
before they become popular.
Um,
that we can kind of,
in our own heads,
hopefully predict that they will,
uh,
become very popular stories.
It's Kinda this weird game,
this kind of,
we call it behind the scenes,
we call them like a pressure users,
like users,
they can predict the future,
the tastemakers and news.
Um,
and it's really interesting because as
we start to surface these stories,
um,
we also are finding likeminded
individuals and so in the future on dig,
not only we will say,
okay,
you know,
we realize you've been digging stories
about a oolong tea in the R,
so here's some awesome stories that you
might find interesting,
but you know,
here's 10 other users that you're
constantly agreeing with that you had no
idea you were agreeing with.
And so we're gonna start making those
introductions.
Um,
and once we do that,
I mean we want to have meetups and get
together.
There's things where people can come out
and say like,
Hey,
you know,
I really enjoyed that story that you
submitted and like make those
connections,
those real world connections.
Um,
so it's,
it's,
it's pretty cool and it's fun and
hopefully we'll have that feature out in
a,
in a few months.
What it comes down to is the quality of
content and who's writing the articles.
Um,
I think that if,
if dig has done anything,
it's really leveled the playing field,
um,
for traditional media.
So,
you know,
a story can come from the New York Times
or from somebody whose blog that they
run out of their basement and receive a,
the same amount of traffic,
you know,
I,
um,
which is,
which is insane,
which just wasn't possible a few years
ago.
I mean,
to think that there could be a story on
the front page of the New York Times
that,
that doesn't get as much traffic as
some.
Someone's blog that makes the front page
of Digg is just crazy.
But it's great because really what it's
doing is it's saying it's really not
about the one destination so much as it
is about the quality of the article and
the story that's being presented right
and what people want to read.
So,
um,
for us,
uh,
you know,
I've seen a lot of people in traditional
media writers that have said,
um,
you know,
my blog is now popular enough to where
I'm receiving enough ad revenue where I
could consider doing this full time.
You know,
I can leave my nine to five and say,
okay,
this is my blog,
this is who I am as a writer and uh,
and,
and do that.
And there's been several people malick
who wrote for a business to Oh,
left and started his own,
a network of blog sites that are doing
quite well.
And um,
you know,
I think it just gives people more
options in the future.
But I mean quality will always,
always prevail.
And I think that there's going to be a,
uh,
place in,
in need for that and there's going to be
a need for people that do the deep dive
when it comes to news and,
you know,
the fact checking and the people that
they're still going to need to need to
be teams around certain types of
stories.
Um,
and that's always going to survive.
The deep dive is being defined slightly
differently now than,
than it was,
I mean,
when,
when you think about the way that a
traditional newspapers would do that,
they would have a team working on a
story that would follow that story
throughout its lifespan.
Right?
And do the follow ups,
the fact checking and all that.
Now all of these users that are editors
on dig and,
and uh,
by editors,
I mean registered users that submit
stories.
They're the ones that are doing the fact
checking.
I mean,
without a doubt,
we have stories every single day that
are marked and flagged as an accurate,
you know,
there'll be a story that submitted,
hits the front page and the users,
they have different barry options and if
they go and they do the research and
they,
they've checked the different sites and
then say,
okay,
this doesn't add up.
They'll submit it in the comments.
They'll oftentimes submit a followup
story and the flag,
the articles inaccurate and they'll say
that right at the top of the article.
So that,
that happens all the time.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
it really,
it really comes down to,
um,
uh,
I mean,
I don't think that's going away,
I think is,
it's slightly evolving when it comes to
dig,
but traditional websites,
I'm sure we'll still have that,
um,
because they need that for their own
kind of a set of stories in their own
personal site,
their own,
their own branded site.
Um,
but for us it's very much this living
and breathing thing that happens on dig
where,
you know,
store will come up and then there'll be
a rebuttal to that story that comes up,
you know,
a few hours later and it's constant news
is just getting pushed down.
So it's just the way that we do it
in discussions that we have with
traditional media when they come in and
they say,
okay,
you know,
oftentimes we'll,
we'll get phone calls and say,
Hey,
can you meet with us?
We just want to sit down and have a
conversation about where things are
headed.
And um,
we sit down and say,
okay,
you know,
obviously you guys have just exploded on
the scene and now you're the second or
third highest a referral traffic to our
site and we just want to know how can we
work with you better?
And I think that one of the things I'm
dig will do in the future,
it's kind of refined some of these tools
for these publisher sites and say,
okay,
what type of information can we give
them a tool to make to really inform
their writers and,
and,
and educate them about what the masses
are wanting and really shortening kind
of the feedback loop,
you know,
it's,
it's really about the message that
they're getting from their readers in
real time as opposed to printing
something and just hoping people are
going to like it,
you know.
Um,
and those are tools that we're working
on and stuff that we'll have out,
uh,
in the future.
Can't really say,
oh,
10 more about that.
But it's,
it's good.